[Music]
if anyone asks you the appropriate
viewing age for this show just pause it
here and point out the rats unexploded
bombs many discarded weapons and highly
psychotropic mushrooms
so pretty much a replacement for daniel
tiger i assume this sugar glump is
looking like he may have a serious case
of ocular swamp leakage
i refuse to believe he is a candy rather
than use furs for warmth this kid kills
them to create a fur pile
many many many many many dead creatures
for a fur pile
come on grab your friends grabbing your
friends by the face with your [ __ ]
yeah you think you're pretty way up
there but i can get you then why not
start at that height you know she's
going to fly
let me just add three more drops of
explosive diarrhea
well there's an unexpected visual
someone's in a lab bucket in the poo
slush is sucked into a vial am i
sciencing right
ah also not sure what got finn so
excited there was it bubble gum saying
the word corpse
it was bubble gum saying the word corpse
wasn't it necrophiniac
oh mr creampuff we used to date
kinky why is that beaker so big how
would bubblegum have even carried it to
the cemetery it's larger than she is
they're going to be attracted to the
candy kingdom why because the candy
people are made of sugar
ding-dong not pictured ding-dongs also
princess bubble gum would be adventurous
at tv sins
adventure time of darkness quickly to
the kingdom
but there don't seem to be that many of
them they're only like seven graves
affected and they don't seem that hard
to kill so why wouldn't you just take
care of the zombies first
and then your protecting the kingdom
portion of the day is over candy
centipedes
listen dark show masquerading as sweet
candy goodness if you're gonna show us a
sentient candy bar with a bite taken out
of it and a dead
candy heart with a bite missing you're
gonna have to explain how many bites it
takes to kill candy at some point
can you people explode when they get
scared that's the correct conclusion but
how did finn get there from bubblegum's
piss-poor attempt at charades that looks
like she means they will also turn into
zombies
royal promise not to let anyone find out
about the zombies
ever to be fair finding out about the
zombies is fine that's the best part of
the show so when you get to all the
socio-economical debating the governor
and then eventually negan is when
everyone starts losing interest
now i must cloister myself in the lab
and finish the equation to my
decorzinator serum cloistering yourself
how would an ice cream cone stay frozen
here this guy needs an olaf flurry cloud
of convenience
and what happens when the candle burns
down on this candy does it wake up daily
with a new candle and when the scalp
scalds it knows to go to bed
is this an eternal flame i didn't know
he was chocolate
that's cupcakist dare i
dare you to tell me the truth about
what's going on
in your mind truth or dare has very few
rules but one of them is you can't turn
your dare into a question of truth
so here's a sin for not following the
simple rules of a game that's sole
purpose is to get people to either eat
something gross or touch a boob
i'd rather play dodge socks i'm not
playing dodge socks clearly
jake didn't even try to move you know
what time it is adventure time
roll commercials you mean this noise
distraction dancing what is this
undulating colon of darkness back here
more candy folk why not animate them
considering it's just one more row
we're gonna smash some pinatas except
for you manfred
but if pinatas are sentient here then
why would they ever smash them at all
sure finn is tricking them into killing
zombies but they don't know finn is
tricking them into killing zombies so
are they willingly murdering pinatas not
named manfred why is this show so dark
where's your undulating colon of
darkness now
this works
this is really really bad finn an
avoidable circumstance considering that
when the royal promise was made princess
bubblegum chose to vaguely repeat
herself rather than use the extra time
to briefly explain the dire consequences
of breaking said promise
that's stupid i agree finn where the
[ __ ] is that fire coming from
we can literally see the inside of his
mouth and all that's there is a bunch of
balls
balls mathematical celebrating math
what's happening princess you've
magically avoided having glass shards
rip apart your body despite the gumball
machines exploding directly beside you
that's what's happening
[Music]
and so princess bubblegum and all of our
candy folk lived for an eternity never
able to rest in peace
a new breed of candy zombies starchy
whoa this guy literally exploded into
tiny bits at the graveyard
how did they manage to find even a
single discernible piece of candy in the
graveyard
if i break a royal promise i get to
fight zombies throw slumber parties but
you were already doing those two things
when you were keeping the royal promise
semantics don't squeeze me out fart
this candy ball with a mustache just
farted to end this episode and honestly
it may be the most normal thing that
happened the entire time
i made you and i can break you just as
easily
if you've ever wanted to know what it's
like to probe into the back end of
cinemasins and learn our deepest darkest
secrets behind the sins podcast is just
what you need each week writers aaron
that's me today that's me
and jonathan yep discuss what it takes
to create the content that you enjoy on
youtube
hopefully enjoy they probably do i mean
even if they don't we talk about it
that's true
i guess i'll just wrap this up real
quick and let you know that you can
listen to behind the scenes
here on youtube or search for the show
on your favorite podcast player yep
pick up that platter tough guy 500
street fights and you can consider
yourself a legitimate tough guy
run for your lives everyone
you need to promise royal promise
not to let anyone find out about the
zombies ever
i promise i'll never leave you you must
now
answer math question
you've got mighty math powers too two
plus two
solve it or die the answer is
four you taste so [ __ ]